so alexi just about set to go against an
angels team that now has guaranteed a
losing season with their 82nd loss
and this one up the middle flagged out
there back of second base and what a
play by kinder philippa i didn't realize
that was a line drive
i thought that was like a one hopper he
caught that out of the air for the first
out of the game whatever it was you're
gonna see some great agility to be able
to take four or five steps and dive and
catch that ball because that ball was
hit hard probably over a hundred miles
an hour and you see the kind of agility
that kinder fellow has when he's able to
make that kind of a play on the mound
for the angels it's 25 year old rookie
left-hander packy naughton trying to put
the bad taste of his last start behind
him
and he misses low that's ball four eight
pitch walk for kinder philippa
and he hits this ball sharply into right
field that's a base hit kinder fuller
drops anchor at second and the rangers
have the first two men
on o2 pitch is a ground ball to third
mayfield to go the short way nothing
comes at the lead off walk and single
the rangers are turned away in the first
jack mayfield will lead things off for
the angels 2-2
swing and a miss strike three mayfield
for a strikeout of the night for aj
alexey
and there's a man aboard now for max
stassi heim gets in there again
and stassi sends a ball to deep left
that's gonna go
[Music]
two run shot for max stassi and the
angels strike first tonight
there's one that's up above the zone
lined out to ride and what a play
a dolly garcia was cheating like mad
that ball
has never been caught in this ballpark
before
the only way you get that is to cheat in
your positioning that's amazing he
cheated and got a great jump but that's
a line shot
in foul territory looks like he's taking
a home run away from him never see a
ball caught there like that
here comes martin with the one strike
offering it's hit hard back up the
middle and in the center of base hit for
culberson who continues to torch lefties
he's been the rangers best hitter from a
batting average standpoint against
lefties all year coming in batting 336.
this ball belted down the left field
line by jonah heim it'll get culverts
into the plate
heim cruises to second with the rbi
double and he's got the rangers on the
board it's a two to one ball game this
loads the bases for andy ibanez
[Applause]
out to left field that's a base hit gets
two runs to the plate and the rangers
have taken the lead heim and tavares
both score on the avanias two run single
and it's three to two
it's a man throwing there's a bouncer
down to first base they'll go to second
for one back to first naughton couldn't
get to the bag in time and i don't think
it would have mattered garcia drives in
a run on the fielder's choice
and the rangers lead four to two
hey that's a fair ball as it skips up
the line in right field
walsh will turn this into two bases a
two out double in the halo half of the
third
goslin lifts this one out to center
field but that's not going to carry for
him tavares
gets back there and he makes the catch
and the inning is done ortega works on
the third base side of the rubber from
the wind-up smoothly into the delivery
and the two two pitches hit on the
ground towards the middle underneath the
glove of renjifo trickles into short
center field as solac takes a big turn
but stops at first
keep our eyes on those all night long
there's a wave and a miss the runner
goes throw down to second base is in
plenty of time to get solace
3-2 pitch runner goes this one lined out
to right field garcia has it might have
a play at first here comes a throw
got him
another outfield assist from el bombay
he's unbelievable
[Applause]
two-two pitch and a swing and a miss
stassi
strikes out to end the inning
and a quick strikeout victim of andrew
wants to start inning number five
got him swinging tied him up with a
pitch inside and it is one two three
fifth for every once leaving things off
shohei ohtani colby ended up getting two
men out went two thirds of an inning in
here he throws a fastball on the outside
corner for a called third strike ohtani
rung up
for the first out here in the top half
of the sixth inning that was a quality
pitch there from colby
the 2-2 pitch and he swings and misses
that one and wants has another strikeout
you convinced me not that i needed to be
convinced this soft flare into right
field is tracked down
in right field by rojas but he couldn't
quite get to it before it hit the turf
so that's going to drop in
i'm with the base hit his second of the
night
tavares sends a drive out to center
field harmlessly enough for marsh to
retire the side
played six complete it's still 4-2 texas
this one lying down into left field and
that one gets past gosselin
[Applause]
around second he'll head for third and
he'll be in there with a triple
second triple of the year for andy
ibanez
gosling made up his mind that he's going
to try to catch this ball it's a hanging
breaking ball
that abandons rips into left field
and as it turned out it was a nice
aggressive try
by gosling but it was a ball he really
didn't have a chance to catch
and then it kind of ate him up he wasn't
able to block it
and when it was all said and done banyas
ended up at third base
now
garcia 3-2
and this one lined over short that's a
base hit abanez scores
and that is rbi number 88
for adolesce garcia and he now is tied
for the rangers rookie record and now
ninth inning last chance
for the angels and they will have to
contend with the rangers closer joe
barlow
there's a tapper left side of the
infield this time holt cutting across
the other direction able to throw out
the base runner mayfield and the inning
and ball game
over rangers win it five to two they
take the opener
in this series against the angels